ん
では
最も有名な発言ですが変革についての発言ですがあるバターインスタンからです
こう言いました crazy っていうのはこれ同じことを繰り返し行い違う結構を
予期することですと彼がいましたこの定義に私が付け加えるとしたら同じ事を繰り返し
て考え
違う結果を予期するのはクレイジーであるということです
ではどうしてこれを申し上げるかっていうと
まあ簡単にいいますと実は今の支給との接し方は持続不可能です
そして今のリーダーたちがこの状況を変えようとしてないからです
次世代のため私たちの行動だけではなく
考え方も
変えないとダメです
me
投資するとしたらマインドセット改革への投資が最も重要でしょう
人間が非常に進化してきました
点滴がほとんどなくなりましたまあもっとも目立つのが最も目立つ点滴といえば自分
自身と時間です
しかし地球は
今まで人間が加えた被害を安には地球が全くを急いでいないようです
地球との調和をとるには数百元
数百万年かかるかもしれませんがまず調和をとるか廊下それを決めるのは私たち自身
です
まず自分の自信と時間がありますそして人間は生存の道具として優れた知能と認知
思っておりますただ生存するだけでは良いのか
それか豊かな将来にするのかそれが重要なのか問われています
では次の3つのことを提唱したいと思います
人間同士と人間と環境とのやり取りの中でバランスのとれた持続可能な状況に根本的に
変えるには次の3つのことを提唱します
そして3つとも大きなマインドセット改革が必要ですが想像力と好奇心を生かせて
コラボレーションすれば将来的に強い地球に帰れると確信しています
まずエンパワーメント力を与えることです
おかしいと思いませんか
男女平等を唱えながら
衣にえいえんの不平等につながるようなステレオタイプを衣に植え付けるのは変だと
思いませんか
男の子は男らしく女の子は男らし
女は女の子は女らしくと
男性は男の子は強くて大黒柱になると女性は静かで控えめでなければならないと教えて
みます
男の子に対しておねえとか女ぽいとを言って
男は感情さえないといけないと教えてしまいます
そうするとこういうステレオタイプ教え込むことで女性が自信を持てなくなりそして
男性が不安になりストレスを抱えるような音の質になってしまいます従って私が提唱し
たいのは
まずすべての人1かる当たるような社会を作りましょう
女性らしいリーダーシップと男性らしいリーダーシップそれぞれの特徴がバランスよく
共存できるようにしましょう
人皆がユニークであり秒レアであると次世代おっしゃる
次世代に教えることです
これが重要なチャンスに恵恵まれています
今のマインドセットを書いて
二票券っていう概念自体が存在しなくていいような社会を私たちが作ろうではありませ
んか
衣に力を与えれば
そうすると
新しい世界を作れることになります
ジョセフ中ベルはこう言いました教えることは2倍学ぶことです
ですからバランスのとれた社会を受けられるように衣に教えれば私たちもその重要性を
再認識できるでしょう
二つ目の低床は湯のベーションです
アインス単位によるクレイジーの定義ですが企業たちと一緒に仕事するとよく思い出し
ます
まあ特に日本の企業もそうです
今まで通りの研究開発の主要だけでは
どうしてインスピレーションに富んだ素晴らしい製品を作れる
と通して企業がそう思うのでしょうか
日本はリスク回避型の社会だと何度も聞か聞かされたことがあります
しかし
この考えを払拭すれば
その辺額をより早く実現できるのではないかと思います
いつもリスクを避けた方がいいと何度も聞かされたらこれが自ら達成させるような予言
となり自分の想像力が下がる下がります
しかし無限の可能性があると言われたら想像力が上がるでしょう
そう思いませんかん
この部屋にあるすべてのものは昔不可能だと思われたのでしょう
私が使っているマイクもそうですし携帯までもそうです
勇気と想像力があれば
夢を実現できます
私はこういますまずパラダイムシフトを起こしましょう
想像力や遊び心を軸にしたらいかがでしょうか
これが会社の組織においても
それを実現しましょう
そして子供のように自ら制約をかけずに無限の可能性を否定せずに
地球での生活に関しても物事を考えてみましょう
子どもたちが無限の可能性の発想のもとイノベーションに富んだアイディアによく
思いつきます
監修まれ様消費者主義は持続不可能です
ですから会社や地球を強くするために子供たちから学んだ雷影でしょうか
への米種のためダイバーシティ対応性が必要です
[ __ ]会には役員会に多様性のある薬が多く入った場合社会中の70億人のニーズをより
よく
捕まる捕まえるでしょう
ジャズ
上座2キャンベルは自分の幸せを得っていう概念を提唱しています
つまり自分の大好きな仕事を見つけてそれをこなせば良いということです
ですから
社員が自分の大好きな仕事ができるように力を与えれば私たちの世界が確かに変わり
ます
自分の幸せの追求がより良いワークライフバランスでもつながるでしょう
ですから会社では新しい発想のもと新しい組織をつくった方がいいと思います
社員の本当の可能性を見出して
会社にとっての重要な
光剣士になれるような葬式が必要だと思います
ただ薬や役職の定義や数字目標から個人の才能やアイディアにフォーカスを
を変えなければなりません
まず競争についてです
今の世界ですと
まあより大きくより速くより強くならなければなりません
こういう世界ですちょっと物議を醸すようなことを言います
ダーウィンの進化料についてコメントします彼の適者生存の背よりが社会の基本になっ
ています
ですからこういうセオリーがあるからこそ
今の男性10位社会の根拠になってきたと思います
しかし大自然を見れば
ミクロレベルでしか見られませんしかしマイクロバブルではコラボレーションと競争に
よってエコシステムが持続可能になっています
人間だけはその他の動物の主とコラボレーションをしていません
人だけが違って人間同士が競争し合ってるって言うことによって破壊的なマインド
セットになってしまい結局いこシストの破壊につながってきたと
思われていますコラボレーションがハーモニー賞は状態にもつながります
そうすると生存のために全ての生物がお互いに頼りあっているということです
例えば三ッ橋がなくなくなくなればどうなのでしょうか
三ッ橋が受粉するすべての植物がなくなりその植物を食べる動物も結局なくなります
人間までもそうですですから生態系が非常に脆弱です
て人間がタイトル大きなダメージが今も現れ始めています
人間が植物連鎖の top に立ってますなぜなら競争社会に必要な武器を作れるし式
を
人間が持っているからですしかしコラボレーションへのマインドセット
改革ができればその知識を生かして
よりバランスのとれた生態系に貢献できるでしょう
最後です
すべての人に力を力を与えるような文化や社会を作れば人の想像力や好奇心を生かして
競争ではなくコラボレーションにシフトできれば
世界が大きく
変わるでしょう
今まで当然だと思ったことをもう一度見つめながら
その工程
元年固定回年8
恐怖心を断ち切ればマインドセットが変わってくることに気づくでしょう
そして最終的に私たちの航路も変わりますそしてクレージの連鎖を断ち切れるでしょう
コラボレーションといた傘のレンズはとなりますそして新しい考え方や行動のおかげと
なりますありがとうございます